let me pull this up we have this from
Gallup right here
in uh 2020 is this 2022 2023 I'm sorry
September 1st 2023 the approval rating
for Congress is at 17 look at that right
after 9 11. I know I was trying to
figure out what that was I know look at
that seven false flags are 17 17 and my
question is to Thomas Massey legitimate
I am not being a dick I'm genuinely
asking for what reason do we want to
preserve the current iteration of an
institution that has 82 percent
disapproval not only does defy any
Democratic standard but even if we want
to operate on a super majority principle
or just say it should be representative
and not direct democracy I think it's
fair to say when 82 percent of people
are like we don't like what you're doing
it's time to change this system it's a
simple choice you know deadlock or allow
the government to steal your money and
then Finance it and give it to Ukrainian
oligarchs that of course will be using
it for their own purposes what do you
want I prefer the deadlock so it's not
even about Ukraine I mean I know that's
a big talking point right now but let's
just talk about the problems this
country has faced at the left has been
screaming about that we've been talking
about how many years did we get the
Flint Water Crisis as big news with
Democrats saying we got to fix these
pipes you know what I say my answer is
deal we stopped funding war in foreign
countries be it Afghanistan what Syria
whatever and I'll I say we divert that
money to the pipes in Newark in
Pittsburgh in Flint and you know what
then because it doesn't cost that much
money to fix the pipes we launch a
commission to start going and hiring
contractors to fix pipes everywhere
better yet we can build Bridges fix our
roads we can hire American construction
workers hey maybe we can build a Bollard
fence down on the southern border with
the money that we're spending I like how
you're thinking out of graphene you know
what Ian deal I tell you this we have a
deal we stopped funding the war in
Ukraine Afghanistan Syria all of these
foreign excursions that have done
nothing for the American people and
Congress approve secure fencing and
homes we'll start we'll start doing
homes yeah and we'll build it out of
graphene if that's what you want you can
3D print tubes and then lock them into
joints and make like domed housing
really cheap with that stuff they
actually there's yeah uh was it geodesic
domes we talked about they they actually
they inflate a big bag and then they
they wire they put wire around it and
cement it and then deflate the bag and
it creates like a donut that's smart
look at that part of the reason why I'm
going a little hand heavy on it right
now is because at a um Rice University
they figured out how to create hydrogen
fuel
um and every kilogram of fuel they're
making out of like waste they'll hit it
with lasers and make it it produces a
byproduct of graphene of four dollars
and fifty cents worth of graphene for
every kilogram we're trying to find a
use for that so we actually make it
before this you had to spend money to
get hydrogen now you're making money
because you're getting a product in the
in the and then you can make Electronics
out of it or you can burn it and I will
and I will I will grab that particularly
esoteric concept and bring it back to
this if Congress came out with a bill
that said we will take new fuel
byproducts to produce products here in
this country and create American jobs
they're approval it would be higher I I
if Kevin McCarthy came out banging and
screaming about the need to fund
graphene their approval rating would be
higher Ian there's a bunch of comments
right now with people talking about you
laying down pipes I'm not going to get
into that one but but but you know you
guys are talking about some very
interesting Concepts about what you guys
want Congress to do I don't want them to
do anything stop taking my money stop
trying to fix problems leave people
alone let the free market fix whatever
problems are occurred that usually are
occurred by the government so I think if
the government steps away from our life
stops intervening stops taxing stops
regulating stops saying you could do
this but you can't do this stops
favoring the multinational corporations
of the banking Elite then I think life
would be better for everyone and I think
if they just took a step back allowed
the free market to be a free market
everything would be way better than it
is agreed and the starting point is not
that we just overnight say we no longer
have any spending at all I think
realistically there's so much we don't
see in terms of federal spending that we
would like and would need at least to
get to point where we can get away from
this kind of thing but the obvious and
immediate is veteran benefits oh God I I
don't think any anyone in their right
mind is going to be like let's just cut
the government off like when we were we
were talking about haha the government's
shutting down matt Gates like no it
means veterans aren't going to get paid
like that's not a good thing and we're
like right right we're we're kind of
just goofing off fair point but he did
say one of the first things we get
through if we're not going to fund the
government is making sure that our
veterans get paid I I do not like the
idea that whether you like the wars or
the foreign policy or not I don't like
the idea that anybody who's who served
in my name would be left high and dry
without benefits I would gladly pay if
that was the case so when we talk about
we want the government spending our
money I completely agree with Luke as it
pertains to their corporate bodies
revolving to our policies and then as it
pertains to the good men and women in
uniform who served us in our nation
whether or not our leaders have led them
astray I think these people deserve more
money you know a lot more money part of
why there's been so much pushback
against what Matt's doing and uh to
destroy the Omnibus spending pack
concept is that it's literally and I'm
using the word correctly here completely
and totally impossible for the 430
people in Congress or however many to
read all those bills they don't have
enough time oh God no so we're gonna
have to complete change the way that our
Republic functions and let the people
read the bills decentral is lies
they should not be spending that much
money so there are priorities when like
Matt Gates said you know they come to me
and said we've got to fund the military
we've got to fund veterans like easy get
the bill it's approved like we we all
agree it's done there's no question
there's no obstruction every member of
Congress says yes to that but then they
want to fund the Department of Education
now there's a debate
the issue is
or how many is it 430 oh is it 435 I
don't know that uh members of Congress
if they can't read that many bills
should not be voting on them and
spending the money or we should have
more members of Congress because
we used to have one for every 70 000
people now we have one for every like
nine hundred thousand and that's true
functionally well they don't function I
want people to represent themselves
honestly and I'm kind of tired of
Representative thing I understand the
stop Gap if you don't want the mob to go
crazy but people have the ability to
govern themselves and I think we should
use modern technology to do it I
disagree I agree Grand technology and
modern technology but I don't think you
want people who look my view is this we
certainly want decentralized power I
like the idea of Representatives I don't
like the idea of how they've been
basically exploiting and lying to us but
the issue is if you are a Tradesman if
you are a teacher or a nurse you don't
follow politics all day every day and
that means someone whose job it is to
provide a service outside of politics
needs to be able to trust you to go to
you and say hey man I trust you to do
what's right you're a good person I give
you my vote and that person takes up
their whole time and energy focusing on
policy issues and making the country
work I'm fine with that the problem is
for too long corrupt individuals have
been like these suckers actually
believed me and they're ripping
everybody off and they're lying about it
it's too easy to bribe because there's
so few of them but but Ian the Pakistani
gender studies are not going to fund
themselves okay who's going to fund the
Sri Lankan speed boats who's going to
fund all these other programs that of
course are absolutely pointless and
steal your money for no reason who's
going to do it okay I like I like the um
America first idea like you're proposing
honestly like there's so much that this
country needs there's so much we could
do so much good here that could be done
I mean shouldn't we at least Focus here
first before we send all this money
overseas and I think that that's a real
frustration I think that that is the
good thing that came out of this
um and I do agree the 82 percent who are
very unhappy with Congress would
probably be a lot happier if they
actually saw the impact of all of this
exorbitant spending but no one ever sees
it you go into like LaGuardia Airport I
remember I used to Flying to LaGuardia
if it was raining there would be like
trash cans there to catch the rain water
and I was like God this is what some
people see when they first arrive in the
United States of America this is the
first impression we are supposed to be
the leader of the Free World and the
superpower and yet this is how our
country is functioning right now look at
something different yeah I think Donald
Trump actually exemplifies the problem
of government in a union way outside of
just the uh just outside of the fact
that they just strapped weights to him
falsely accused him of tons of things
they're trying to persecute him
prosecute them I think you look at
someone who built this this Empire knows
how to run multiple companies creates
multiple Brands the left tries to argue
but look at all those bankruptcies it's
the stupidest argument ever 500 plus
companies and a handful of bankruptcies
and bankruptcies don't mean failure it
means you're literally preserving the
business
but you take someone like that he
becomes president still gets things done
despite what's going on and this and the
challenges he still faced show
when you when you go to the government
and say hey we need to put up say like
suicide Nets on the Golden Gate Bridge
half a billion dollars later oh it gets
done you go to the private sector and
they compete over it and 10 million
dollars later it gets done I guess what
was the old saying uh when in 2016 uh uh
under budget and had a schedule yeah
that's how he operated as a businessman
and I actually think that when he became
president he believed he could get so
much accomplished and he thought well
gosh if I just run things like I did a
business then it will say I mean you he
would talk about Lockheed Martin he
renegotiated for the new Air Force Ones
which by the way will start flying in
2025 just in time for him to arrive on
them president but he he actually tried
to save money he tried to do all these
things he went to South Korea and he
said why is it that that you know we're
funding all of this stuff over here for
you guys you can fund it yourself we're
going to stop sending a bunch of money
over here to you you could find your
some of your own stuff he saved the the
country I mean unknown amounts of money
that no one ever talks about and it made
zero difference no one talked about it
no one cared about it and I think it's
insane that you can have someone with
the the ability like he had and yet this
government is in such a mess that it
really made almost no difference well to
be fair he did also spend a lot of money
and he did also increase the the deficit
and the debt a lot I do think he had a
lot of policies that were very favorable
towards blue collar workers I think more
favorable than any other president uh in
our time but the deficit was increased a
lot under his presidency and I think I
think we're still dealing with those
ramifications today because of that I
kind of see the difference of running
the country and a business as like um
the solution to our economy isn't in
money it's not in finance it's in the
productive capability so you could print
shitloads of money and build graphene
factories and start producing massive
hydrogen fuel and make us the wealthiest
country on Earth but just printing the
money like it doesn't take money to do
that I mean we can print much money as
we want right now so we just need to
incentivize people to do it we need our
factories back we need manufacturing
back we need to produce things here in
this country we do you know how hard it
is to get anything really made in
America for any a decent amount of money
everything is so expensive to do here we
have to change that otherwise we're
we're going to be in a really bad spot
look at covid look at the supply chain
how much we learned how much you know we
realized we really weren't doing here
yeah you need to make it here you need
to incentivize business here in this
country absolutely the hard chemicals
like East Palestine when that train
derailment would often it annihilated
the community like that's why we moved a
lot of that stuff over to China's
because like if it spills we don't want
to spill next door so I but I do believe
the risk of having the Chinese producing
this stuff is outweighs the risk of
contamination but I mean contamination
is devastating too I just yeah it's like
a two-sided coin that obviously you know
what it is I understand it's these
climate change policies and so what
Democrats do is they say okay you can't
make a business that has XM out of
carbon or whatever so the companies say
Okay China it is so when when Joe Biden
comes in this is why I think they're
lying I think they are full of it Joe
Biden says we're going to bring back
these restrictions climate change is bad
now you can't produce x amount of carbon
you have this these taxes you have these
fees but hey we're going to remove
tariffs so you can import products for
free he is outright telling businesses
send your fancy factories to China yep
that's exactly right and I mean it it's
so devastating in so many different ways
I think too our country I mean if you
look at inflation if you look at the the
job situation in this country this is
this is a I don't want to say it's an
easy fix but it seems so obvious and it
was all set up so well I give my
father-in-law a lot of credit the
tariffs on China the trade deals that he
negotiated with China I mean who would
have ever thought we'd have something
like that honestly yeah yeah he was the
guy that actually opened my eyes to the
danger of our relationship with the CCP
I didn't yeah I knew it was like tenant
I knew it was not good terrifying I just
didn't until he was like China China and
I was like okay I still don't get it but
then eventually I started to realize
they produce the antibiotics you know if
they cut off right if they poison our
antibiotics like with fentanyl and one
day they just decide ninety percent
China is waiting right now and
salivating over what they see happening
in this country the fact that Joe Biden
is our president that we see him in a
weakened state that our economy doesn't
seem like it's it's headed in the right
direction for the long term they are
ready to pounce and take over as the
superpower of the world and Donald Trump
was the first to call them on it thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time